well for many of you parents you've
likely noticed your kids are doing more
schoolwork on tablets and computers so
we looked at what's keeping your kids
safe when they're on school working
online when they're in school what
happens also when something goes wrong
the school days of books binders and a
number two pencil have passed students
now work write and learn using computers
chromebooks tablets and technology
this can engender opportunities for
students to find inappropriate sites it
also matters with parents and schools
we're all on the same page that we're
all trying to protect these kids before
ccsd students are allowed internet
access they sign a digital waiver an
acceptable use policy agreeing to use
school technology for school work the
district also uses programs to filter
content are all embedded with two
different technologies there's go
guardian and then there's also beacon
goguardian software helps schools manage
students devices and then those monitor
they're not spying on the kids they
don't activate the cameras you know when
people don't want the cameras on what
they do is it monitors what the kids do
beacon is a tool that allows
administrators to track and report on
student interventions it can if needed
turn a computer off even though they
might act mature they might might be on
their game with grades they're still
kids in the case of more extreme
behavior these technologies can help get
ahead of a crisis if a student type
something alarming where can i buy a gun
it'll send an alert to the school who
then alert the proper authorities the
school's action plan would then kick
into high gear it may end up that you
get a knock on your door with you know
local law enforcement school police or
any of our partners in the valley making
sure that everything's okay or it may
just be that the school gets a you know
a message saying hey you may want to
talk to this kid because they've looked
at something hundreds of thousands of
chromebooks have been issued out in the
district and the vast majority of the
focus is just keeping kids on task
focused on school work and staying safe
in the cyber world i feel that kids
should spend more time being kids